and so now we'll have our concluding
address and David rhew has generously
agreed to do this for us David is an
architect theorist and director of
recline which encompasses a wide array
of experimentation their projects
intertwine artificial and natural
regimes that are shaping an ever more
synthetic world from collaborating on
the use of 3d printers to print live
tissue cultures to investigating the
retrieval of energy from tidal cycles
david is expanding the reach of
architectural intelligence and to not
other only disciplines but uncharted
territories of invention and thought his
design work is matched by an equally
significant commitment architectural
discourse as Avett david nearly
single-handedly was responsible for
introducing object-oriented ontology
into architecture a fact that will
either land him in some small or large
corner of architectural history or as
Robert AM Stern told me when I started
to become interested in triple o maybe
the biggest wh oh oh oh my career but
with both Peter Eisenman and Robert AM
Stern allied against triple' oh one can
only be sure that David was on to
something that he was doing the exactly
right thing David received his Master of
Architecture from Columbia University
and his BA from st. John's College where
he studied architecture and mathematics
and as we previously heard was a
classmate of Graham Harmon and they
played the saxophone together and Yale
has an incredible archive and I've
actually found footage of them no I'm
just kidding
david has recently defected and in my
view is the Benedict Arnold of
architecture for leaving the East Coast
to take over as the chair of
postgraduate studies at sci-arc in Los
Angeles which I think he will use to
towards great effect and it will be a
real asset to the school but we do miss
him on this Coast so please help me
welcome David rhew as we perhaps
dangerously offer him the final word to
the symposium as he delivers our
concluding address
we could put up the first line I'm
pretty visual so I find it difficult to
speak unless I'm looking at pictures of
myself yeah out of well thank you Mark
and thank you Deborah and also thank you
to the students yeah it's awful awful
job to do this I out of respect to my
friends my colleagues and also to this
institution I kind of worked hard to
make a prepared statement which I threw
most of away this morning and have been
scratching notes all over three pieces
of paper and I have horrible handwriting
so this is not going to be as smooth as
I anticipated but hopefully a little bit
more engaging the title of my final
remarks here is minority reports plural
so just a little bit that I salvaged
from what I prepared
there's nothing worse for the architect
than the phrase that's not realistic
that simple phrase can be a shorthand
for many things it's too costly
it looks structurally unsound it won't
work with our program and functions no
one will know how to build it etcetera
etc etc however the most interesting
version of why something seems
unrealistic is this one it looks weird
in other words the proposed architecture
doesn't reflect how reality should
but I wonder for whom it looks weird for
whom I always joke around with my
students some hypothetical thought
experiment of let's say we have a time
machine let's go back and bring Thomas
Jefferson back to the present and make
him use Google Earth and so you can see
what has come of the Jeffersonian grid
and he would probably have a heart
attack right there on the spot I think
every thing that we would call familiar
or normal was all at one time a pretty
weird idea but it seems to the weirdness
seems to advance at a kind of glacial
pace so it always seems normal
so I think you need a kind of separation
of the timescale to see just how weird
things have become if we indeed have no
access to the ultimate reality of things
what we think reality is pertains more
to what we think reality ought to look
like than to anything we can actually
prove or verify as real it is for me but
a small consolation that through our
cleverly constructed dialectical
telescopes we may have verified at least
that the real is indeed there but
nonetheless we are trapped in the misery
of representations we know all too well
that this is not a real type but is it
even a real painting
to maybe try to address a little bit
more closely the aesthetics of politics
or what am I mean to be more activist as
makers of things this is something that
sent me on an almost ten year long study
of the sublime both in making stuff and
also reading stuff and talking about
stuff what you see here is a painting by
Thomas Moran and as the story goes there
were strange stories of a hell-like
region of the American West and that's
how it was actually quoted somebody who
nearly died and saw a kind of bubbling
cauldron of weird stuff like nothing we
had ever seen before and Lewis and Clark
became furious it led eventually to a US
Geological Survey expedition to verify
that this was in fact there but
Ferdinand VanDerveer Hayden then
director of the US Geological Survey had
an interesting idea he was going to
bring 30 photographers with them and
what was then one of the most painters
of landscapes at that time which was
Thomas Moran and Thomas Moran produced a
thoroughly exaggerated perhaps all too
subjective representation of what he had
seen or what dancing and aside from the
more documentary images that the
photographer stood which to some degree
may be a
the fact is Atiya bout its existence it
was Moran's paintings and sketches that
thoroughly captivated those members of
Congress who then shortly thereafter
within a year instituted the idea of the
National Park Service this was the
painting the Grand Canyon of the
Yellowstone that Thomas Moran did after
this was instituted which was then being
used perhaps as a as a kind of maybe not
the killer and enough she's here
as a kind of sneaky strategy of then
building public consensus around this
legislative act and the quotes were
quite interesting all kinds of quotes
about well what's once described as hell
on earth now being described as a
wonderland and I want to go there you
know I want to go to there maybe like
speak like Tina Fey yeah yeah but it was
it's not an altogether happy story
because it was a marketing of this
geological object to a public for
consumption and for enjoyment and they
did not go to Yellowstone to see in some
sense what is maybe there and who will
ever know what that really is like an
extent they went there to feel this
whatever this is and it's hard to verify
if there's even any agreement about what
each person is expecting to feel this is
the frustration the frustrating thing
about the sublime I think ultimately
Thomas Moran also fascinated me for like
the other Hudson River Valley School
painters like Frederic Church for
modifying certain cliches of the picture
of the sublime coming from the European
tradition the obvious thing to observe
is the human avatar which is quite
typical say in the paintings of Caspar
David Friedrich has been erased
why because you the beholder is the
avatar yourself you don't need to think
through the avatar to think about the
sublime it's about simply being immersed
in it you are at that person you are the
wander in the mist later on the sublime
becomes quite interesting because the
subject matter of the sublime makes a
very strange transformation in the
American culture and this is complex
cultural history but it's there for you
to find out more about I can't really do
justice to it but read some stuff by Leo
Marx and David Knight the subject matter
of the sublime which was this nature
this other that's out there everything
but us turns into that everything that
is us that tech not technological
monstrosities that were beginning to
build and it's not just this is the sexy
one but it's also about things like
hoover dam and railroad and as david
nine points out that most provocatively
may be closest to our time the internet
i remember quite well what it was like
to first open up mosaic it was a strange
feeling like poking through a doorway
into this other and it was deeply
enjoyable and terrified but words failed
because it's not really about terror
it's not how I would use our word
normally when I would say I'm terrified
and like most of you I'm hardly ever
terrified maybe that's part of what it's
like to be as such
today that you're almost never turf i I
like Cedric dull cells work quite a bit
and I find this quite interesting and
for all of us delicious irony is this
kind of strange a substitution Andry
mixing of this history of thinking about
this sublime other is turning into I
think something else and I liked it very
much because the frustration of the
sublime ultimately became who are these
people looking at the sublime who is
this is that me can I identify with this
figure what about also the passivity you
just stuck there you know in all staring
you have no agency you're not
participating and the this thing on the
other side this other may not really be
as much of an other as we might think it
is before I came here I knew I wanted to
force maybe a more direct and perhaps
done address of what it might mean to be
an activist through statics so I asked
my former student that sci-arc when you
chain to research for me all the weird
subcultures she could find I gave her a
format I said put into the middle the
person put into another column their
representations and in the final column
just some text description
their label and most importantly for me
their equipment
this one I found the most hilarious
health goth
I found the this piece I don't know if
it's a spoof or it's serious
you can't tell anymore these days it
seems all of reality at least a reality
you can encounter through contemporary
media that is the internet seems
entirely perfect at all times I've given
up trying to verify but somebody wrote
in New York magazine a FAQ about FAQ
about how to be a health dog so I want
to share with you some of this because I
found it absolutely hilarious absurd and
interesting it writes somewhere in
between norm corps cyber Punk goth
sportswear chic exists a possible
possible real trend known as health god
it's been kicking around since spring
actually but it seems to have entered
the mainstream this week much to the
chagrin of og health gods all over the
world somebody either asked somebody
what oh geez stood for original gangster
yeah now I know yeah but what is health
goth everyone asks here's a quick FAQ
for it so you to make immune in the
graveyard or gym with ease what does the
term mean it's exactly what it sounds
like
or for a more intellectual approach
here's some fancy rhetoric from and
disks explainer health goth relies on an
anti nostalgic dystopian present
refracting the other capital o by means
of an exaggerated profile and tribal
aesthetics health goth creates a proto
narrative of returning to paradise lost
by embracing mortality as a
world consciousness and devotion as
means that deliver us from late
capitalism you can laugh I flamed it's
Clarence I was rolling on the floor
health God speaks to an intrinsic
psychic connection with the elements be
they be they fire water or fauna and the
ability to incorporate ambient nature
into the corporeal realm the second
piece I got just three I'll be quick
where did the trend originate according
to complex health goth was born of the
dark recesses on a Facebook page started
by cool Portland musicians might grab
Erick and Jeremy Scott they told the
magazine that they were attributing a
name to describe a feeling that already
existed that feeling of sadness but also
sportiness good you should be laughing
and finally this one's brief but wait a
second will my patron saint Emily
Dickinson approve of this embrace of
athleticism one of the tenants laid out
in the health cough Bible decrees
workout until your near death so yes yes
she would yeah anyway I particularly
like the sports bra with the upside-down
Nike symbol that says I just can't
one thing may be slightly more serious I
started I wanted my assistant to focus
on the equipment because I was
suspicious about the formation of small
constituencies because nonetheless what
IA new of it you need the equipment you
need the objects you need design and
who's making it who's who's making money
often but what I found nearly across the
boards is a absolute dedication to you
would find words like hacking remix in
misappropriating and also you see the
word estranging so just that upside down
nike symbol may not be that different
from some of the things me and my
friends might want to think about but
anyway what I learned from seeing this
research come back it's really not about
health goth at all because I don't know
if any of you are thinking I'm about to
announce health gauntlets the next thing
for architecture it is the sheer number
of little constituencies the sheer
number of subcultures and I'm trying to
deliberately say little constituencies
instead of subculture
let me silently flip through this for a
little bit
Michael yarn that you have
this one's pretty weird mark I'll speed
up because there's a lot of these this
one's fast worth checking out
Google is successful to us all just look
it up anyway these are all the rest and
there's a lot more a lot more yeah so I
I prefer the term small constituency
because subculture is maybe a dismissive
way to refer to this because subculture
assumes big culture de culture and what
we might actually be seeing is that
there is no big culture out there what
we're seeing is almost Cambrian
explosion like multiplication of little
constituencies everywhere everywhere
from Kinshasa to Cleveland to New Haven
you see the multiplication of these
small constituencies and what might be
striking if you haven't noticed is I
think our students know this better than
we do whereas at one time when maybe
there was a big Authority and a big
culture you could expect they rationally
constructed constituency to discuss
which aesthetics might be deemed
appropriate for that collective and
reinforces the values that were all
committed to but what I see happening
here is the aesthetic seems to come
before the people and then before the
values what seems to only matter is to
remix the things that we seem to be
obligated to use and buy maybe break it
if you will and then and that's an
interesting question why you know why
does anxiety about it about objects it's
a I see it more as an anxiety about
objects than a kind of dedication to it
and then isn't it strange that the
people or the collectives that start
forming around these objects this
equipment don't even know exactly what
they believe in until seemingly later so
we know quite well given what's
happening these days that the single
most common political position that
you'll find in say the young loosely
defined because I kind of feel this way
too there of a kind of none of the above
commitment because the binary political
structure or in some countries a single
party system of totalitarian regimes
that there's no way to identify with the
definition of what we belong to but does
this suggests then we simply need more
more pot parties what does it look like
if you go three party what's a
three-party system look like I think we
know but what about a two hundred party
system what about a ten thousand party
system what does that look like what
does it look like when the bronies go to
war again
the health guards something I enjoyed in
generally enjoy above being in academia
is this Kenai freakish dedication we
have to civility pass around the
microphones like the Talking Stick and
survivor and wait for the other to speak
so I sympathize with one thing to cut
through some of that crap and insights
of friction maybe and maybe call for a
structure of agonism but I I think the
civility is important because I think it
is a unique space within the institution
and other than the kind of Foucault
version of why to hate institutions I
actually love institutions for how it
clears out maybe a completely imaginary
fictional space where we have freedom
and space to hesitate and think about
things that maybe cannot be legitimized
by the marketplace or by normal
realities by whatever it is that's out
there so in conclusion I would like to
make three observations and three maybe
if I could be so bold declarations of
things to work out all right one when
you see the absolute explosion of these
little constituencies and I think from
the ivory tower it can look like just so
much noise that it's kind of a kind of
worse worthless victimization
nopales through the in gestation of
signs and symbols but I think even
although it may look like that for us it
may not look like that from the other
side and I was thinking when Jacque runs
here yes last night was talking about
just a problem of having time I think
one of the consequences of the
absolutely negligible amount of labor it
now takes to copy and this is as I am
hinting a kind of extension at the
benjamine idea and observation that in
some sense it's kind of a taken labor
out of it or maybe not entirely out of
it but it's made the amount of labor
that it takes to produce an aesthetic
regime so negligible that basically you
know anybody can do it yeah and I find
that interesting and something worth
thinking about also I think once you see
this I think it's very tempting and out
of this kind of observation distant
observation that we might have from our
space this kind of disgusting display of
exchange and seeing the misery of
representation we can pound the table
and call for a return to single culture
and reassert the authorities say of our
discipline and so on but I I wasn't sure
but as I'm getting old I'm becoming
quite confident that I think is utterly
foolish to assert single Authority once
again Humpty Dumpty has fallen and
shattered and two very strange pieces it
seems
is the answer to glue it back together
into single Authority I think that's not
even possible
or should we grind it up into powder and
somehow parametrically pulp it back into
the featureless misshapen hole you all
know I'm talking about yeah it is
foolish to insist on a return to single
Authority number one number two it may
be true that at one time big
constituencies purposefully chose big
aesthetics to reinforce ambitious values
but today small aesthetics build small
constituencies to reinforce modest
values and I think that's a good thing
or at least we don't see what's coming
down the pipe and how this all goes
wrong I can't see without even knowing
number three without even knowing we in
academic space may accidentally slip
into becoming our own strange little
constituencies with our own remixed
equipment and our weird our own weird
representations what do we think of this
are we just as really on the same level
as health counts
we're just yet another small
constituency but maybe it's good to
maybe think about what might be our
constituency and what are the values
that were actually insisting upon so
those are my three observations three
things to work on
I think that continues to be the
extremely important and precious work of
academia to disenchant representations
of the real but this should not be done
I think to the exclusion of every other
kind of work I'm glad there are smart
people researching the strange
permutations of late capitalism I'm glad
there are people doing real research
into globalization and the effects of
capital on the transformations of
mutations of the open ground and I could
go down the list I think there are many
extremely important projects out there
most of whom are dedicated and relative
to whom speaking tonight there are all
kind of projects of disenchantment kind
of evaporating what seems like voodoo or
magic showing what's really going on I
think it's incredibly precious valuable
work but it can't be the only work we do
whereas it is the job of some to
disenchant existing representations I
think it is also the extremely important
job of others to reap then re-inject the
world with newer and perhaps sneakier
representations but also again we have
to be mindful
Riaan chanting for whom and for what
reason and finally I think this is what
I personally want to work on moving
forward in fact this is one I'm gonna do
in studio in the spring and Sarah I am
really honored to be speaking with Greg
recruits in front of me because he's a
kind of personal hero to me
but the thing that intrigued me the most
about the work was there was one image I
saw
of the set that was constructed from one
of the photographs and whereas I think
maybe an obvious thing to think about
initially it would be the estrangement
of the content itself the picture that
we make and this questionable to what
degree architecture produces content
because I am I also thought that was a
fantastic observation that Michael Young
made about the the necessity it may be
of architecture to be received in the
state of distraction and kind of pulling
out and putting back content or backed
into the background and but what I
thought was so interesting was the
construction and the design of the set
which is to some degree content lists
and background to the pictures that will
eventually be made I'm very curious to
explore what it would mean to think
about architecture then as an apparatus
making for aesthetics and not to say
it's just gonna be a steel frame and
let's just stuff whatever you want but I
think that's an extremely difficult
question for architecture to be mindful
of its background status and to discover
what might be like a system while at the
same time always keeping an eye on the
forms of estrangement that it will
engender and to be sneaky about it and
as a final word I want to thank Mark for
this invitation to curiosity I think
that's a really great way to put it
and I want to thank you know Graham and
Timothy because all I ever wanted to do
was to just try to understand something
and then go back to work
their work came across my desk and an
interesting time where I was feeling
very frustrated because I was feeling
like it was becoming impossible to do my
work or at least difficult to do my work
and I wanted to exit to try to
understand something different maybe to
think about what was making it's so
difficult to do my work and perhaps
impossible to do my work but ultimately
I want to go back to work
so the playbook of manifesto writing
everybody get on the wagon and let's
speed down the doors of the man I you
can do it if you want but I'm not
interested yeah because I don't think
the so-called man is actually out there
I also you said I want to make the most
beautiful photograph I can that's
ultimately what I want to do I just want
to make the most beautiful architecture
I can that's a problematic word I know
especially after these three days what
that even means and what if we even
using the right word Beauty sublime or
remix the weird thing I don't know you
know but ultimately yeah I think that's
where I'd like to head next my thanks to
all of you and thanks for great great
conference
sorry really wonderful wrap-up to
everything
thank you for everybody attending I know
it's a Saturday hard to give up
especially on a nice Saturday and thank
you most of all to all the participants
some of you have come from very very far
away and we really really appreciate it
I know going to New Haven isn't exactly
that vacation junket that some places
might be but we really are deeply
appreciative so please join us upstairs
on the second floor for our final round
of drinks and we'll continue the
conversation there thank you